yeah maybe yeah no I think Alicia Farr
hang and syed hussain ii have a clear
goal the young men from Afghanistan want
to make sports history in san moritz
switzerland they are training for the
2018 olympic winter games in the history
of Afghanistan known has been to do
winter olympic this will be for the
first time in this exciting and is I
feel great about it but the same time is
not that easy to too good to medium
turns switch coach Christoph circa gives
clear instructions this is the third
winter the Afghans have spent in the
Alps training professionally from
November through March
when I came here I was really beginners
I didn't ski mostly I was crashing with
the disc is and I always i was falling
down the olympic hopefuls relax in a
hostel where they live here in
Switzerland when they're home in
Afghanistan they both attend university
as children sayad and Alicia experienced
the horrors of light under the Taliban
their families had to hide even today
their home province BAM Yan is one of
the poorest regions in the world at an
altitude of two and a half thousand
meters it is mountainous with lots of
snow and no infrastructure when
Christoph talker was traveling in
Afghanistan he was impressed by the
enthusiasm of the people he decided to
do something for the country and to
sponsor to Afghan skiers to come to
Switzerland gone to mom for giving the
alcohol we started out just going around
and asking if anyone was interested in
skiing there were a lot at first but
many soon gave up constant practice and
training is not considered standard
procedure in Afghanistan like it is for
us so a lot of them dropped out but
these two were really persistent Vicky
hot leggy throng suka founded the Banyan
Ski Club which covers the young men's
training and living expenses in
Switzerland the money comes from
donations and an annual benefit race
Afghan style all the participants have
to schlep their equipment up the
mountain before they're allowed to
descend culturally it's totally
different you know but when you're in
the mountain and there's not so much
difference is to the mountain
environment the contrast is down in the
valley san moritz is one of the most
expensive alpine holiday resorts Oh
sayad and ali shah find it all a bit
much you create it were not even the
subject of these portraits mean nothing
to them oh no I cannot say with this
not really but that's no wonder what of
James Bond and Marilyn Monroe got they
were skiing Alicia and Sian came to the
sport later the most serious competitors
they have a lot of work to do if they
hope to keep up the first I was thinking
about to have fun ever from this game
and then later I understand for the
eraser you we have two more work and we
have two more patient and we have two
more actively active the moment of truth
this is the first time they're
participating in an international race
the competition is strong most of them
practically grew up on skis unlike sayad
and Ali Shah but the novices aren't in
it to win they just want to qualify it
doesn't matter how her his scales is but
it's good we were part of the racing
team sayad is the second to last to
start the run is worn down and I see
despite limited visibility he can't
afford to form that would jeopardize his
chances of participating in the world
championships but the young Afghan
masters the giant slalom and safely
crosses the finish line his coach
Christophe circa is happy as a shower
also puts in a fine performance I'm not
going for champions I'm going for
Afghanistan to put the flag Afghanistan
beside another flex I've succeeded in
that this winter they'll rise in the
alpine world ski championships as the
first-ever ski team to represent their
country the first step toward the 2018
winter olympics
you
[Music]